[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNY GOVE: So good morning.
My name's Jenny Gove and
I'm a lead researcher
on the Google Pay team.
BRANDON HERRING:
Hello, everyone.
I'm Brandon Herring and I'm
the design lead for Google Pay.
JENNY GOVE: And
today we're going
to look at how to design great
payment experiences with Google
Pay.
We're going to cover what
we've learned with partner
integrations and
integrating Google Pay
into some of our own
products, and we'll
talk about how you can
easily create great checkout
experiences to
get great results.
Through watching many usability
studies over the years,
I'm well aware that
e-commerce experiences
can be the high points
of frustration for users.
That's because they're
often the low points
of the entire
shopping experience.
There's friction everywhere.
You start typing in information,
but something's wrong, right?
Red errors appear in
the forms, addresses
don't match so you try again.
You add your credit card
number, but it's wrong.
And so you try that again.
You need to create an
account, but the password
isn't strong enough
and you get told that
and you need to think again.
Or the two passwords don't match
or you already have a password
but you can't remember it.
Every one of these
experiences represents
an opportunity for a user
to decide it's not worth it.
At every red error, at
every point of friction,
users can abandon
their purchase.
This results in lost sales
for retailers and lots
of irritation for users.
In fact, we recently
did an audit
in Europe of more
than 400 top sites
and found that very many
of the basic things that we
should do correctly for forms
are not being implemented.
For example, we found
that 46% of top sites
don't implement error
messaging in real time.
So when users make an error,
they don't know about it
until they go to hit the Submit
button, and then they're told.
And then they have to look
for where that error is.
It means that almost
half of the top sites
don't optimize their error
messaging for ease of use.
And we found that 29% of sites
don't allow users to navigate
back and forth in the flow--
perhaps in the checkout
experience--
without losing information
that they've already entered.
So these types of issues
lead to much frustration
for users who are trying to
complete their transaction.
So it's no wonder that
69% of digital carts
are abandoned before the
purchase has been completed.
These numbers represent
a significant opportunity
to improve the
experience for consumers
and to create checkout
flows that bring
delight in their simplicity.
Earlier this year, we
announced that we've
unified our payment
systems and products
under one brand, Google Pay.
And today, we want
to talk to you
about how Google Pay is changing
the way people pay for things
online and in stores.
BRANDON HERRING: So Google
Pay gives users one place
to easily manage all
their payment information.
From seeing the cards
and keeping sure
that they're up to date
to seeing their latest
transactions, Google
Pay is giving users
a flexible and comprehensive
digital wallet.
And users, they can leverage
this account information
to speed through checkout, in
apps, online, and in-store.
The app already has more
than 100 million installs,
which is incredible.
That's enabling top merchants
from DoorDash to Lyft to Airbnb
and a lot more to enable
seamless checkouts
for their users.
And Google Pay is
powering transactions
across our first
party properties,
from the Google Assistant to
the Play Store, Chrome, YouTube,
and more.
When developers
implement Google Pay,
they can create experiences
without payment forms,
super easy for users,
really easy for developers
to implement.
And users, with a payment method
linked to their Google account,
can checkout instantly anywhere
they see the Google Pay button.
And because hundreds of
millions of payment methods
are already saved to
Google accounts today,
developers can
start to implement
this solution across the
globe immediately and deliver
at Google scale.
With Google Pay,
users are instantly
ready to check out the first
time they visit an app or site
or even in a guest
check out flow.
They no longer need to
add a payment method
to every single merchant that
they want to transact with,
they can zip through check
out quickly and easily.
And with less friction, the
user experience has improved,
users are happier, and
transactions increase.
And we're seeing this
already validated
with a lot of our partners.
Hotel Tonight has
found that customers
who were enabled
with Google Pay were
65% more likely to
complete a booking flow,
and Airbnb has seen their
traction volume jump
11 times since implementing the
latest version of Google Pay.
And Jenny is going to tell
us a little bit about how
we got there.
JENNY GOVE: Thank you, Brandon.
So we're going to
talk about some
of the best principles
that went into creating
Google Pay, the practices
around how you can develop
great checkout experiences
with the system effectively,
and a little bit about
how Google Pay is enabling
assistive transactions
with voice.
Because consumer products
are dependent on the user
experience, we started with
a user-focused approach
to meet those needs.
We began defining
an overall vision
of what we wanted
to do to create
safe and easy check out
experiences for everyone
everywhere.
We informed our vision
through conducting
foundational research and
then we carried our learnings
from this into our design work.
And then we iterated
on the designs,
all infomed through user
testing and usability testing.
And we published
developer guidelines
for our community of developers.
We're continuing to update
and improve and optimize
our platform for consumers
and for developers.
Let's look at this
user-centered approach
again with more specifics
about the activities
that we took for each phase.
So our first step involved
conducting research
to understand the
broader picture,
the users needs around
payments and their lives.
And we visited different
regions across the globe.
We went to Europe and
North and South America
and we visited Asia and we
explored users payment methods
and needs through
conducting research there.
We learned about the importance
of speed and efficiency,
security and privacy.
And these learnings have
really shaped the design work
that we've done for Google Pay.
Taking these learnings, we
established a set of principles
and created a design system
that would meet those needs.
And we tested our designs
with usability studies.
In key phases of the
product development,
we ran studies every
two weeks, iterating
as we uncovered issues and
we could make improvements
to the product.
We dedicated ourselves
to the details
and to getting it
right with our users.
We also iterated through
conducting live experiments
with our partners, and used
this data in a complementary way
to inform our design decisions.
Based on all our learnings
throughout this process,
we published guidelines
for developers
in order to take
advantage of this work
and make implementation
clear and easy.
BRANDON HERRING: So let's take
a look at some of the principles
that we established that guided
us through the process Jenny
just talked about.
First and foremost,
Google Pay has to be fast.
We know users want a
quick and easy checkout
flow and experience online.
We want to remove that friction
with a lightweight UI that's
super intuitive to use
and easy for users.
And we've seen this in practice.
With Game Time,
which is an app that
lets users purchase tickets
for events and concerts
they want to go to, Google
Pay is front and center
the moment a user encounters
an event they want to attend.
Even before they've signed in,
they're already ready to pay.
Because of this, users can check
out and purchase their tickets
in only two taps.
Google Pay loads
a lightweight UI
that shows them their
account, the payment
method they're going to use.
One more tap, they're done.
It's really fast,
it's super easy.
And that means for
Game Time users,
all they really need to
worry about is whether or not
their favorite team is going
to make the playoffs this year.
And I'm optimistic about mine,
so fingers crossed there.
This is obviously
great for users,
but this efficiency
also leads to results.
Game Time found that
users who had Google Pay
were two times higher
to convert than users
who just had a payment
card saved to Game Time.
So in other words,
even when the user
has a payment method already
saved with a merchant,
the seamlessness that
Google Pay can offer
leads to a higher
conversion rate.
The second principle
was around scale.
So this meant a
few things to us.
We needed to address
a global audience,
we needed to support a
variety of payment methods.
We also needed to
create a place where
users can update their payment
information once and have
it available anywhere
they sign in.
And of course, we
also need to make
sure we're supporting more than
just the Android ecosystem,
that we're across browser and
we're across OS, some of which
we announced this week.
So we have to enable users to
check out quickly and easily,
no matter where they are.
With our first
party integrations,
we already support a wide
variety of payment methods.
And we're bringing this
scalability to developers,
letting users pick
however they want to pay,
from leveraging all the
payment methods they have
on file with Google
to new experiences,
like eMoney for in-store in
Japan and Paypal for in-store.
We make it really easy to
implement localized buttons.
That lets developers
reach a global audience.
And we've made it really
easy to manage your payment
methods too.
Now users can update
that information
in the Google Pay
app, iOS or Android,
or on the Google Pay web and
have that immediately available
anywhere they're signed in.
This is a huge win
for users, but it's
a really big win for
developers, because it ensures
that a user's payment
information is going
to be available and
work on any app or site
that they want to transact with.
And of course, Google Pay
needs to work anywhere
they can access their Google
account, so across operating
systems from Android to iOS--
which we just
announced-- and browsers
beyond just Chrome, but into
Safari, Firefox, and more,
enabling people to
check out regardless
of browser preference
or device preference.
This expands the reach
that developers have
and it increases
the user benefit.
JENNY GOVE: Now we know
from conducting research
that one of the single
biggest concerns that users
have with digital payments
is around security.
And we've worked
hard to give users
the security, transparency,
and control they need to feel
confident in each transaction.
The importance of
security, as I mentioned,
comes up again and
again in user research.
We know that it's both important
to be secure but also to convey
that security to users.
With Google Pay, we meet
these needs from the base up,
from secure storage
infrastructure,
card tokenization,
and authentication,
through communications
such as notification
and supplemental technologies
such as device security.
So let's take a closer look.
As you'd expect, Google Pay
rests on Google's secure data
storage infrastructure, using
industry standard encryption
to keep your payment
details safe.
For transactions, we support
and encourage tokenization
for install and
online use cases.
Users transacting with cards
issued from supporting banks
can tokenize these
in the Google Pay app
and then transmit a
virtual account number--
the token-- instead
of the real one
when they pay at
participating merchants.
We've also worked with payment
gateways and processors,
to securely transmit
payment credentials online.
But beyond the actual
underlying technology,
it's important to
reinforce security
through conveying
information about
transactions transparently.
We provide transaction
notifications
for supporter cards,
so consumers know
if a transaction is being made.
Notifications is
just one of the ways
that we're communicating
transactions to users.
We're also combining
the transaction history
across Google properties, your
website and apps and stores,
into a single place, on our
mobile and web platforms.
And this provides a new
destination for users
to view their transactions.
Device security is
also important to users
when considering payments.
Android users can use the
Find my Device Service
to remotely locate a
lost device, of course,
and one that's associated
with a Google account.
And then, they can secure
that device immediately,
remotely from a distance.
And in terms of
user authentication,
we're currently exploring
different practices.
For example in the
Play Store, we've
implemented user control
options for the scheduling
of authentication,
as you can see here.
Users can choose to
authenticate on purchases
on Google Play on their device
and set a schedule for when
this happens.
And there's the option
to switch from password
to fingerprint authentication
as they purchase.
Here you can see this
option in Settings
and a request for a
password to confirm that.
And in the third
screen, the confirmation
that the fingerprint
authentication
has been selected.
The user now has their new
fingerprint authentication
option as they purchase.
So we're giving users
security, but also convenience
within their checkout flow.
Google Pay is secured
in multiple ways
and we're continually learning
about and improving the way
we convey that security
to our consumers,
so that they can
transact with confidence.
And all of this
means that when users
see Google Pay in your
app or on your site,
they're more likely to
choose it as a way to pay,
because they trust it to handle
their transactions securely,
as well as quickly and easily.
The last principle that
we're going to review here
is about delivering an
experience that's unified.
We've unified our
services and we've also
made it simpler for
users to get started
and to pay anywhere with
their Google account.
Specifically, we've created
a singular destination,
which brings together all
of the payment activity
under this unified brand.
And in addition, we've
added new payment use cases
and functionality to our app.
When we talked about
security just now,
we talked about user experience
principle of transparency
being important.
And one way we're achieving
this through Google Pay
is with this
unified destination,
for users to see and manage
their payment information
and activity.
Having an overview for
transactions and payment
methods gives users a lot of
peace of mind, we've found.
With the Google Pay app,
we've brought together
all the functionality relevant
to people's broader payment
experiences.
The home screen of
the Google Pay app
shows the users
in-store payment methods
as well as helpful information,
like their latest transactions
that they've made, and
contextual information
like nearby places that they
can use stored loyalty cards
or stored gift cards.
With Google Pay, users
now have the ability
to see and manage all of
their payment information,
from tokens for
in-store payments
to payment methods
they've already
stored in their Google account.
This is also where
users can fix anything
that requires their attention,
such as updating existing cards
or adding new cards
to their account.
In addition to storing
merchant loyalty cards,
Google Pay now stores tickets.
So concert tickets,
sporting tickets,
and train and plane tickets.
These can all now be kept
in one easy to find place,
and they can be redeemed
through barcodes or NFC.
Peer-to-peer payment
functionality will also soon
be fully integrated into
Google Pay, making it easier
to pay friends back or family
back for shared expenses.
And recently, we've
launched new experiences
supporting mobile transit
in cities like London,
Las Vegas, and Portland.
And additional
transit agencies are
coming on board, such as tram,
metro, rail, and bus systems
in Birmingham and the entirety
of the West Midlands in the UK.
Including support for
activities like transit,
loyalty, and paying
friends, means
that Google Pay can be
relied upon by hundreds
of millions of users as
a daily transaction tool.
And in this, we're
building invested users
and a trusted ecosystem for
your businesses to rely on.
And this adds up to a
comprehensive payment
solution that
keeps users engaged
and they're ready
to pay anywhere.
BRANDON HERRING: Great.
So I want to do a
quick demo, just
to show how quick
you can actually
check out with Google Pay.
So if you could switch
to the demo, please.
So I'm going to
use DoorDash today.
And Jenny, are you
getting hungry yet?
It's a little early, but--
JENNY GOVE: Yeah, something
for lunch would be great.
BRANDON HERRING: All right.
Let's see.
So we'll get some Mexican food.
All right.
And I've never added a
payment method to this app,
so I'm just going
to get going here.
We'll do a quesadilla,
maybe veggie.
Add that.
JENNY GOVE: That sounds good.
Can we have something
with chicken?
BRANDON HERRING: Yes.
How about let's do a
burrito with chicken.
Sounds good.
All right, I'm going
to add that to my cart.
And so now, I'm
going to go check out
my cart and everything
there looks great.
So I'm going to check out.
And this is the point where
as a user, I start to sweat.
My heart rate goes
up, right, because I
know there's a form
that's going to ask
for all this information.
But when I look
here, I'm actually
already ready to pay because I
have Google Pay on this phone.
So I'm going to just
place the order.
And that's it.
I'm actually not
going to continue,
because I don't think we'll
get to where this food's going
to be delivered in time.
But if I hit this button,
the burritos are on the way.
So if we can switch
back to the slides now.
Thank you.
So I just want to highlight
a couple of things
that I think DoorDash did
pretty well on this flow.
First when I looked
at my cart, they
surfaced all the
relevant details
and they made it
really easy to review.
This is a really critical
step to make sure you're not
surprising users.
And I'm actually going to talk
a little more about this later.
But they made it
really easy to see
what I'd ordered, if
I had special orders,
if I made any special requests,
fees associated with that,
the tax, delivery, et cetera.
And then when I
got to check out,
they just defaulted
me to Google Pay.
As a user, I didn't
have to think about it.
I didn't have to say, oh,
maybe I'll try Google Pay.
It just was already
there and it worked.
This is a huge benefit to
having to avoid check out,
having to make users
think about it, right?
It avoided forms and it
kept the entire flow really,
really smooth.
Of course, you can start to
leverage this immediately with
the site g.co/pay/developers.
That's got all the API
details for you to check out.
JENNY GOVE: All right.
Now unfortunately,
we know of course
that forms aren't going away.
But when a user does
encounter a payment form,
we've made lots of
improvements to the experience
and made auto-fill an
integral part of Google Pay.
Users really appreciate it
when websites save them time
by automatically filling common
form fields, things like names,
addresses, and credit
card information.
And so auto-fill helps
to bypass all those input
errors we talked about before.
And these can be, as
you know, particularly
prevalent on virtual
keyboards and small devices.
Chrome has billions of
30-day active devices
around the world.
And those users of those
devices are already checking out
with merchants online.
And so this is a
significant pathway
to enabling seamless
payments everywhere
a user is signed into Google.
Our research found
that by correctly
using auto-complete
attributes on your forms,
users complete them
up to 30% faster.
So by ensuring the auto-complete
process is working correctly,
you can improve the online
experience for your users.
As developers, you can
give hints to the browser
by providing both
the name attribute
and the auto-complete
attribute on each input element
to help data to be
auto-completed correctly.
Auto-complete attribute values
are part of the current WoT WG
html standard.
Commonly used auto-complete
attributes are shown here.
And you can find these at
the link provided here.
Now, here are the specific
attributes for credit cards.
One thing to take note
of is that the attribute
for the verification
or security code
is CC-CSC, standing
for Card Security Code.
It's not CCCVC or anything else.
We see that sometimes.
And that simple issue
can cause auto-fill
not to work appropriately.
So let's make sure you
get that one right.
And let me also walk you
through another example
of a common mistake we
see made with auto-fill.
Now, a user experience
best practice
is to label form fields
outside of the fields,
like you can see here.
And that's really good because
it's this permanent reference
for the user of the
type of information
that's needed in that field.
Form fields also
have placeholders,
text that's shown in
the field that typically
give examples of
the sorts of data
that would be placed there.
We've seen developers use
fake placeholders instead
of using placeholder attributes,
and then use JavaScript
to remove that value.
And this makes it
hard for auto-fill
to determine if the
user had inputted
the values versus it being
default text in the field.
And it results in the fields
not being auto-filled.
So that's another
one to watch out
for and make sure you use
that placeholder attribute
appropriately.
So by implementing these
attributes correctly,
you can help ensure that
users don't experience errors
as their form
information is filled in.
More information on
auto-complete attributes
and some of the errors
that commonly occur--
we've got a list of them there--
some best practices can
be found at this link.
So now we've talked about
users using their cards
from Google Pay via auto-fill.
Let's talk about
how we get cards
into Google Pay vis auto-fill.
When a user fills out a form,
their credit card information
is saved to their
Google account, which
ensures that next
time, the user is
ready to pay without having to
add any card information again.
And this saves
the user very much
time and effort in checking out.
It reduces the number of
abandoned checkout experiences
and it grows the
ecosystem, of course,
beyond the hundreds and
millions of cards already saved
to Google accounts.
By aligning auto-fill
with Google Pay,
we're ensuring users know
that the auto-fill payment
information is coming
from their Google account.
The end result is
millions of more people
are users who are ready to pay,
enabling frictionless checkout
experiences for users
and merchants globally.
And that's a win-win.
BRANDON HERRING: So how
can you, as developers,
take full advantage
of Google Pay?
Jenny just walked through some
really great examples of how
auto-fill can really improve
the experience when you leverage
it right and you
fill it out correctly
and you set it up in a way
that's going to work for users.
Integrating the button is going
to make that more seamless.
Because even though auto-fill
is awesome, it's still forms.
And Google Pay bypasses
forms all together.
And so to be effective,
there are a couple
of things that I
want to talk through,
that you guys can keep
in mind when you're
designing with Google Pay.
So first, we covered this,
it's really worth reiterating.
Make Google Pay the default
payment method for users
when they're new to
your site or app.
By doing this, you're
going to really create
that truly magical experience
where payment just happens.
And it's not just
they had to do it.
When they're done, they say,
that was awesome, right?
Users don't have to do
anything and they're
ready to pay before
they even sign in.
Which leads to my next point.
Another really easy way
to streamline the payment
experience is to allow
a guest check out
option for your customers.
Account creation slows
down the process.
It's another form to fill out.
It leads to more frustration
and card abandonment.
There was a recent study from
its called the Baymard Research
Institute, they're an e-commerce
research organization.
They found that forced account
creation was the second biggest
reason for card abandonment.
So the second biggest reason.
So it's a very real threat
to your transaction volume.
And when you integrate Google
Pay into your guest check out,
you just make it really easy for
users to get through and get on
with it.
They don't have
to think about it
and they can complete
that transaction.
Once they have a
successful transaction,
then prompt them to
create an account.
But if you can reduce
that initial friction,
it's really going to
significantly increase
your conversions.
Make sure you display all
relevant transaction details.
You know, when a user sees the
drawer for Google Pay, that's
often the last thing they
see before the transaction,
as we saw in the demo.
So before they do that, you
really want to make sure
you're eliminating
any surprises, any tax
that exists, fees, et cetera.
In that same study from
the Baymard Institute
that I referenced, they
found that 23% of users
abandon purchases because
they didn't see the total cost
upfront.
So that's one in four, folks.
So again, another really
easy thing you can do that's
just going to have an impact.
This example here
is from Fancy, which
is an online shopping site.
It shows a really
good example of them
creating a really scannable,
I can see my shipping cost.
And there's tax and the total
and I can see the amount
and it's all right there.
I don't have to think too much.
It verifies what
I know to be true.
And they're also showing that
I'm going to pay with Google.
And in this case,
they're even showing
that I'm going to use my Amex.
So that's another
important point
that you can minimize
user confusion
if you can surface the payment
method that they're also
using with Google Pay.
This is especially
important when users have
more than one card on file.
There are a lot of ways you
can display this information.
You can use the Google
Pay mark with the card,
you can simply have
it in a text string.
Whatever kind of works
for your site, your app.
But it is a really important
thing that you can do,
to just give users,
again, we're trying
to build trust
through this process
and not make users
have to think and say,
wait, which card did I use?
What was it?
So these are just ways you
can streamline this experience
and keep users moving.
And then once they
have made the purchase,
it's not necessarily over,
right, from a flow standpoint.
They may want to go
find that receipt.
They may have things that
they need to send to somebody.
There's some reason, right?
So when they go look
for that receipt
or when that receipt
comes in, at that point,
also make sure you're
being consistent
and you're displaying this
stuff the exact same way
you displayed it
throughout the process.
So again, build that
trust, keep users moving,
don't make them think
too much about it.
I think in this case,
you also definitely want
to show the payment method
used, because at this point,
the payment's been done and
this is going to just give them
that full context.
The buttons.
The Google Pay buttons
come in two flavors.
There's a dark button,
there's a light button.
In most cases, we
really recommend
that you use the dark button,
because most sites out there
and apps out there are white.
And modern apps and sites
have a lot of white space.
So use that the dark button.
It's really going
to stand out more.
It's going to give users
a really strong CTA.
We've seen implementations
where there are the white button
on the white site.
And you can imagine,
it doesn't stand out
that well and users
are going to miss it.
So this is just another
easy one to keep
users moving through it.
Let them get on with it.
If you do have a dark
site, then the white button
is going to work awesome.
And lastly, for really quick
and easy implementation,
make sure you're using one
of our recommended payment
processors.
In the demo yesterday,
they showed how easy
it was to set up the button.
And part of that is
because these processors
have done a lot of the
logistical work for you.
They make it super
easy to get started.
And you can get a full
list of these guys
at g.co/pay/business.
So hopefully these
details have given you
guys some really concrete things
you can put into place right
now to make sure that you're
enabling customers to check out
really quickly, really easily.
If you want to know more,
you can go to g.co/pay/brand,
and that's going to give you all
the assets and how to use them
and make sure you're
implementing them correctly.
And then at g.co/pay/developers,
you can get more details about
the API.
JENNY GOVE: So now,
we're going to take
a look at some new
experiences with Google Pay.
But before we do
though, let's just
stop to consider that the first
online digital transactions
happened in the mid 1990s.
So it's taken 20 years
of research, design,
and optimization to
get people comfortable
with online purchases.
The e-commerce industry
has come a long way.
And as you've seen,
we at Google are
hard at work making
that even easier
for our users across
a variety of devices.
And as device
capabilities have expanded
beyond traditional
experiences, we've
worked hard to adapt the
lessons of the last two decades
to new modalities
devices support.
While the same principles of
fast and efficient, scalable,
secure, and unified
are just as applicable
for different modalities such
as voice and conversational
transactions, how these
principles are applied
must change.
On phones, users
personal devices,
asking users to
re-verify their identity
before completing a purchase
may add unnecessary friction.
While on a Google Home, if
it's a communal device, say,
shared with family or perhaps
friends living together,
verifying identity could
be very appropriate,
assuring the user they have
control over the purchases that
are made.
We're working towards providing
people with the controls
to make the right authentication
decisions for their context.
And all of this helps
to ensure that when
users want to make a purchase
through the Assistant,
the experience feels
natural and easy.
So let's make a
payment transaction
as applied to
voice transactions.
OK, Google.
Order my usual from Starbucks.
- Hi, Jenny.
Starbucks here.
That's one tall Earl gray.
Anything else?
JENNY GOVE: No, that'll be all.
Thanks.
- And are you picking that
up at your usual Starbucks?
JENNY GOVE: Yes.
- OK.
That'll be $3.45, but the
balance on your Starbucks card
is only $1.04.
Do you want to reload your card?
JENNY GOVE: Yes, put $20 on it.
- OK.
I've added $20 to your
Starbucks card with Google Pay.
Your total is $3.45.
Are you ready to
place the order?
JENNY GOVE: Yes.
- OK.
I put your order in and
it'll be ready soon.
Enjoy.
JENNY GOVE: Great.
Looking forward to that.
BRANDON HERRING: You
should have got two.
JENNY GOVE: As new
devices are introduced
and new interactions
become possible,
we'll continue to invest
in these new modalities,
to ensure that we present our
users with the best experiences
to support their lives.
BRANDON HERRING:
With Google Pay,
we've focused on
making something that's
fast and efficient, scalable
and secure, and really,
a unified brand that is
recognized around the world
as something that's easy to pay.
Right?
Whether that's in-store, online,
or through new experiences,
as Jenny just showed with voice.
Google Pay gives users a totally
seamless checkout experience.
There are hundreds of millions
of payment cards on file,
and that's a huge
benefit for developers
as they start to create the
seamless check out experiences
of today, but also of tomorrow
with assistive experiences
and more.
I think the future is definitely
going to be formless, right,
as we go into more voice.
So this is really awesome
stuff that we can do.
And it kind of leads
to my final point,
which is just I do
think this is a really
exciting time for payments.
There's so much coming.
There's so much cool
stuff happening.
And I'm personally excited
to see what all of you guys
come up with as we move forward.
I want to call out, we have
one more session later today
that's actually going to go into
a lot more detail on the demo
that Jenny just did.
You can learn about all
the Assistant actions.
And so check out Add
Transactional Capabilities
to Your Actions.
And that is on stage 5 at 2:30.
JENNY GOVE: And a
reminder that we
have developer documentation
available at these links.
And we'll be adding to these
as more experiences are
built for Google Pay.
We'd love to hear from you.
So don't forget to
provide feedback
on our session on
the website schedule.
And we'll be in the
sandbox afterwards
to take any questions.
So do come and see us in dome
G. And if you haven't checked
out this already, you can see
some really cool experiences
of future payment
experiences, including
in-store, interactive
retail experiences that
are there in Dome key to try.
So do stop by.
BRANDON HERRING: I
tried it, I tried it.
I tried it and it was very cool.
JENNY GOVE: Enjoy the
rest of IO and thank you
so much for coming.
BRANDON HERRING: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]